why don't you take one with over that
action fees
oh hi this is Andy Daly from Comedy
Central's review and I'm gonna tell you
about my favorite YouTube clips you know
in the writing room for review nobody
likes to work in general and so from
time to time we would just get a burst
of energy from just dialed something up
on the on the screen from YouTube
something to make us all laugh and just
take a break the most reliable thing for
that was the classic Orson Welles doing
commercials action fees he is 100
percent drunk he could not be more drunk
just do anything no psycho goodies we've
heard of the California Wireless
whatever to take three action please the
French Champagne is and it takes you're
just capable and there's one word he's
he's practically asleep when they go
action and he goes ah French Champagne
no is celebrated for its excellence it's
just fantastic and it never gets old
mostly because of the expression of the
poor defenseless extras you are it's
terrible another video I like to watch I
don't know why they call these videos
shredding videos it's not a good name
for what it is to me the best one is
this old black-and-white appearance by
the Beach Boys singing I'd get around
you see the video of a band performing
but the audio has been replaced with
much crappier sounding stuff
like one guy you see like clapping his
hands along with the music it just
sounds terrible when everything else is
taken out except a guy going
[Music]
that is a great one everybody knows when
something goes wrong on the news that's
like the best thing ever
I think it's like a guy is finding out
about local wildlife or something like
that
Texas rat snakes are gonna be one of the
largest snakes you know it's one of
these things where there's an animal
expert talking to the news bandit and
he's a very distinguished newsman with a
voice like this and all of a sudden the
lizard jumps on us that you find in the
Metroplex area responses that I've ever
seen I don't need to tell you to check
out bad lip-syncing bed'll it bad
lip-sync cuz that one's called the rick
perry commercial is a classic someone
had a great a lungfish decorate their
home for married fools function tuna
eggs Doritos cheesecake tamale see you
as well as the Ron Paul commercial a lot
of people say I kind of wish you were
less cuckoo I'm pretty a pretty a pretty
goose for you and a pretty racing car
I'll tell you what I saw
recently it's funny but it's a little
sad it's called something like world's
worst uncle ruins birthday party it's
like a birthday party a little boy is
about to make a wish and blow out the
candles
his uncle was standing behind him and as
a gag his uncle pushes his faces into
the cake what's great about it is that
is the sincere honest angry response
turns into a fight which is a totally
appropriate and he's like what what what
it's a joke all right so that should
keep you busy if you're in a writing
room and you don't want to work I'm glad
to have helped this is Andy Daly enjoy
do yourself a favor and check out orson
welles trying to get through a
commercial for wine having had entirely
too much wine